Zachary karabell you have written this
fascinating book all about how we live
in a world defined by economic
indicators and how just a handful of
them GDP inflation unemployment have
come to define us as a nation even
though as you make of the very good case
they are somewhat flawed and they are of
limited value to a certain degree how do
we get to this point I mean start at the
beginning at the beginning of your book
you go all the way back to 1066 and
William the Conqueror and apparently our
fascination with trying to measure where
we stand in the world is very old yeah I
mean that some let me start from what
why I wrote a book about numbers right
which I'm not a statistician I'm not
even a trained academic economist I mean
I kind of have played one in my
professional career but so I was
interested in this question of how do we
get to live in a world where these
numbers are so woven into our identity
and they're so woven into our
conversation about how we're doing as a
nation any nation not just we as
Americans and that I wasn't that trained
as an historian so the question of like
did was this always the case and no it
wasn't always the case and it was in
fact only the case really very recently
given how central they were so the
question was when did countries when do
people start to want to try to figure
out what was going on economically with
numbers and yeah I do start the book
with 1066 and William the Conqueror
because the first major effort in the
modern world I don't have 1066 is modern
it is a Vere classicist was the Domesday
both the William the Conqueror
Commission's to survey the output of his
realm now you probably have gone back to
the Romans because any Empire from time
immemorial basically wants to know how
much land is under their control how
many troops they can command and how
much farming output because the only
real source of tax revenue is
agriculture so the Domesday book really
is just an effort to count whose farming
what with the glaring exception of not
including the church because the church
wasn't under the authority of the king
this actually previews a big theme of
your book is that even the Domesday book
had its flaws
I mean you would think it would be
pretty simple to go around your realm
and write down you know how much corn or
whatever crop was being grown but even
then what it kind of shows is there's a
big difference between counting and
statistics and there been a lot of
really good books about statistics you
know statistics is the art of sampling a
lot of stuff you count without having to
count it all individually but they
didn't know that in 1066 they just tried
to go around and count everything well
you bring up a really good and that's
what I wanted you to talk about the
birth of statistics because it is very
different from counting right and and
you you point out there's another big
leap forward in terms of attempting to
count stuff when we get to the age of
empires and trade and sort of silly now
you have like global industry and people
are even more interested in who's making
what Goods and where they're headed to
but there does reach this point and tell
us when that is when people realize the
difference between counting and
statistics what statistics do for you
right so sometime in the the Age of
Enlightenment in the 17th century people
realize that one most aspects of human
reality are just too difficult to count
and the other thing is that if you go
and you count like the first thing
people realize if you try to count on
average lifespan right and particularly
in a time when a lot of people didn't
make it past five six seven years old so
if you were to count all infant
mortality when trying to answer the
question of average lifespan your
average lifespan would be unfortunately
extraordinarily low so that was one of
the first efforts to go look to really
get a snapshot in numbers of what's
going on you have to actually make
choices about what to leave out and how
to wait things and then there's a whole
series of mathematical formulas about
how to really do that artfully which
develop in the 17th century in the same
soup that creates the calculus and the
same German and French world of stuff
creating statistics and I mean there's
there there's laspeyres there's there's
a whole number of people that if you're
statistician you kind of remember as the
great minds in the way that we look at
Newton in terms of calculus and and
gravity or Leibnitz but there isn't
really one person who invents this this
is just a rolling series of mathematical
evolutions but and it really takes until
the 19th century before you start
getting
kind of the economic statistics that we
think of now now this book is obviously
hugely focused on the United States and
you make the case that again this
question of counting was ever-present
even in the very beginning of the United
States and very much on the mind of the
founders and in fact makes its way into
the Constitution yeah and I think most
people don't remember because it's not
the most dramatic aspect of the
Constitution we talk about slavery we
talk about north-south and the balance
of small states weak states minority
rights the whole Federalist Papers we
don't usually talk about that the census
is embedded in the Constitution that
every ten years there'd be a count of
the population and this is because if
you're going to have representational
democracy you have to know how many
people you're representing and you have
to decide how many representatives in
the House of Representatives which is
the one part of the government that is
directly key to population is going to
represent but it quickly moves in the
19th century from just how many people
are there and where to hmm you know the
human curiosity to map and to measure
what are these people doing well what's
their employment how many hours they
spend working what's the nature of their
their home life in terms of output and
so you kind of begin this creeping
growth of information about people's
lives economically even though it starts
with just funding who's living where and
how many and so that gets us up to the
end of the 19th century the early 20th
century where we begin to see the
arrival of these modern indicators that
now have come to define us so much I
think most people would be absolutely
astounded I mean most people be
astounded by most things in this book
because the history of this is all
really interesting but I think people be
really surprised to find out that the
birth of a lot of these economic
indicators was driven in a huge part by
the kind of worries and political
controversy the cause of social justice
that came along with the Industrial
Revolution labor unions people worrying
about how much people worked and how
hard they worked and how much were they
keeping and you have the great story of
Ethelbert Stuart tell us a little bit
about him so if you'd asked many people
in the 19th century about something
called unemployment it
would have been a meaningless question
because when you had a purely agrarian
world where you just everybody needed to
work to live literally the idea that you
could be unemployed or without work was
kind of inconceivable particularly
because until the populations explodes
in the late 19th century there's almost
always more things that need doing then
there are bodies capable of doing it so
if you're not working it's either
because you're drunk or you have ill
moral character or you're impaired
somehow the job right you you had work
that needed doing to be fed so it took
the Industrial Revolution and that the
serve the transfer of workforces
from the farms into factories to create
this thing called a job look we're being
we're painting with broad strokes I'm
sure someone could find exception to
these rules and one of the things that
drives the question of like what's the
nature of work right do people have a
job are they getting paid for that job
adequately relative to their needs is
the series of progressive reforms in the
late 19th century that saw this kind of
Industrial Revolution as also really
chaotic and dislocating one in the
United States and one of the people who
is drawn to the the base of the cause of
social justice all ah the late 19th
century is this guy named Ethelbert
Stuart who was trained as a coffin maker
in Illinois and end up being appointed
to the the the Illinois Commission of
labor and then makes his way to
Washington where he joins what was then
the very sleepy
not really well funded and only recently
created Bureau of Labor Statistics and
other fraternity to picture him he I
think of him as a little bit as as if a
statistician met Mark Twain you know
ornery suffered fools not at all and was
a kind of you know I'm going to call a
spade a spade and find the numbers to
measure it kind of guy and when he was
one of these sort of driving forces of
we need a snapshot of employment the
nature of employment patterns to prevent
big business from taking it out of the
unions he's also a man at in the right
time as well too because you have this
confluence of other factors in
particular 1920 1921 we have this
recession it sort of knocks people for a
loop
you've got politicians saying how can we
even measure how bad it is when we don't
know where we started from
and then of course you have the Great
Depression and this seems to push you
very much this desire to count and
understand uh just what we're losing or
how bad it is yes so few things in this
day people like Edward Stuart have been
around in the late 19th century and
people during Fisher who's a Yale
professor who was really interested in
indices into thinking about prices and
what we now call inflation so there had
been some work done before the Great
Depression on what's going on in this
thing we now call the economy and that's
who by the way there nobody used the
word the economy until the early 20th
century and the reason why I can say
that with any confidence is if you use
something called Google's Ngram which is
everything printed digitized in a Google
database and you can play around with it
and find the frequency with which things
were use if you type in the words the
economy into Google's Ngram until about
1930 it flatlines there's almost no
mention of it and then about 1930 it
does this hockey stick and we're just
keeps accelerating since then because
until we create numbers like the
unemployment rate like GDP like
inflation there is no the economy
there's political economy there's the
output of states but there's nothing
called the economy because there's no
means to measure and capture it and it
took the great depression in this
massive dislocation and we didn't know
it was the Great Depression in 1929 all
that people knew and all the toover knew
was some bad things were happening that
actually seemed somewhat worse than
earlier bad things had been happening
cuz there always been bad cycles uh and
and Hoover had been an apostle of
scientific management that was his sort
of calling card to become president was
that he was a more than competent
administrator during the war he was a
minor executive and he believed in
scientific management of everything and
science demands fast facts in the case
of an economy demands numbers 1929 there
were none so he agrees with some of the
movement that have been in place are
ready to fund the Bureau of Labor
Statistics to actually create an
unemployment number and that is the
first time in American history or any
other country's history for that matter
where this notion of an unemployment
number becomes central to our body
politic well now we step though into the
vast complexity of this so you know
coming up with an employment number
involves making lots and lots and lots
of judgments and so these first
characters who you have in your book
they actually had to sit down and say we
are going to count this I'm not going to
count this and this is our definition
talk about some of the over a of
complexities in just designing that
first unemployment the person what does
it mean to be unemployed what does it
mean to have a job doesn't mean you're
working X number of hours a week what
number of hours a week does it mean
you're working I mean at a time when in
the late 19th and early 20th century
people would work 70 hours a week if you
work 40 do you have a job how many hours
you have to work to have a job
do you trust people's
self-identification hi Kim do you have a
job are you going to tell the truth to a
surveyor are the surveyors you're going
to send around going to ask enough
people in that kind of sampling way
because you're not going to survey the
entire population of a country and ask
every single person do you have a job do
you have a job you have to ask a subset
of those people so how do you do that do
you do it geographically if you do it
only in urban areas are you going to
overstate how much unemployment there is
in rural areas if you do it only in
rural how do you decide is it by
populations by demographics is a
bi-state so all these questions have to
be worked out and in nowhere they worked
out initially immediately when I worked
out today and they're still not worked
out today like what and and the
definition of what does it mean to be
unemployed has changed over time in that
it's not not having a job to use a
double- to be unemployed statistically
doesn't mean you're not working
it means you wish to have a full-time
job you you have at least hold the
people asking you that you are looking
actively for a full-time job for a
period of time before you got asked that
question now it's four weeks earlier was
eight and that you are therefore
unemployed because you're looking and
can't get work it's not that you just
don't have work and then we use the term
much more loosely today because we use
it as a kind of thumbs up them down and
even getting to the point of defining it
was immensely complicated that I do that
in there I mean what who made the final
decision again it's if this is a
decision making by by lots of different
voices and people arguing it's not like
there was one person who says this is
the rate and
one was doing its own work at the time
all the very few other countries were I
mean a lot of these the reason why you
should focus on the United States is a
lot of the creation of these numbers
comes from the United States and then
goes global it's not like multiple
societies we're doing this
simultaneously so this desire to kind of
command know understand what's going on
economically stem is at least in our
history from an American initiative and
some British initiatives and then goes
global
so alongside the unemployment rate we
also have the creation of gross domestic
product or the precursors of that rather
tune if this is happening at the same
time you run through this and again you
point out that part of this was about
needing to assess the depths of this
recession that was going on and
understanding what the output of the
country was now versus what maybe it had
been and how we're going to things look
going forward but you also point out and
this is when you get a whole new aspect
into this mix is that what's happening
at this time is that you are also
getting the concept of government as an
economic actor and this again had been
somewhat alien other than in times of
war governments have always been
economic actors in times of war because
they force everything to focus on war
production and supplying armies and one
thing you had in the 1930s was as we
know this huge effort of government
spending in the form of the New Deal in
the United States the the Labour
government in Great Britain was doing
its own form of it and one of the things
that happens in the u.s. is the the
understandable desire of the Roosevelt
administration particularly say to its
critics that yes we've just done all
this completely unprecedented stuff and
spent all this money is it doing any
good is it making things better but
unless you can actually measure this
thing called an economy and its output
and then show its output was acts we
spent a lot of money and look its output
is y and y is bigger than X it's just an
ideological argument which is what it
had been until then so there have been
people back to the Domesday book of
trying to measure the output of a
country economically and there's been
kind of happenstance in academics when
all these things have their seeds before
they become the first time you see
people doing that's really in the 17th
century as well the same time when
statistics s great and then there's like
a lull if there's an efforts and it's
usually rich men who
I think this would be kind of fun you
know the same rich men who do
experiments in their garages they say
what wouldn't be fun to measure the
output of a country and then it kind of
lays low until really the the early 20th
century some efforts in the nineteenth
and the u.s. there's a an émigré
economist russian émigré name's Simon
Kuznets who later wins the Nobel Prize
we obviously know about John Maynard
Keynes in in Britain and people like uh
the Sir Richard stone is another
Eminence of this and they start saying
okay how do we measure output and what's
that even mean what does it mean to
measure the output of a country so
defining that big definition in the
1930s was do you include domestic work
because one of the things women did
largely was cook clean make sure the
home was taken care of I mean I can tell
you if my domestic work were included
like GDP would double we'd go out and
we'd go up immensely so and cousins for
one said look we absolutely should
include this this is a really essential
aspect of economic activity that's
productive in the absence of which is
destructive the argument was made though
unless it has a market price we're not
going to include it so GDP or then
national accounts are simply what is the
market output things that are bought and
sold to have a that has a of a call a
price and a cost and so it was decided
to leave out domestic work because it
was hard to figure out what the but the
cost of that was but this is more than
just an you point out that this is about
Roosevelt administration saying they
wanted to be able to say look we put
this much money in and now this is all
the benefit that came from it was also
the idea I mean Keynesianism it was
about it was had a predictive value or
two in that if you're Kansas then
Keynesian then you believe that you know
if you've got to stimulate demand and in
order to know how much you need to
stimulate demand you actually have to
know where things stand at right and
then you get this dispersed the things
that I guess are a little bit familiar
in our current discussion particularly
after 2008-2009 of like how much output
do you need to stimulate how much demand
you need to simulate what's the gap
between what we're doing and what we
think the optimal or the right level is
we think about that in terms of
employment right so if there's a 6.5
percent of unemployment right now if I
just told you that and you had yeah I
just you were like plopped down here
from Mars there would be no reason to
know whether that was a good number or a
bad number it's only perceived as a bad
I'm not this is not about whether or not
people are finding jobs because we have
this sense of what we think this system
ought to be doing numerically based on
what it did do numerically and none of
that pertained in the 1930s where this
is all kind of being made up as it goes
along we create national accounts and it
allows the Roosevelt administration to
start talking about national income by
the late 1930s and saying look our
national income is going up the next
real catalyst is world war two right
which is that the real challenge for the
United States in World War two was if
we're going to be the armory of the
world how much domestic industry cars
and tractors and whatever we were making
in factories could be shifted to
producing guns and planes and ammunition
without so enfeebling domestic economic
life that you basically win the war but
your economy collapses and in order to
do that you had to understand how much
are we producing how much can we produce
how much more can we produce without
generating scarcity and therefore
inflation which have been the big
Bugaboo of all societies during war and
secret GDP which is very the tool to do
this it would take much longer to
explain exactly how that it was GNP now
its GDP and that was a really potent
tool at least people believed it to be
one of the most essential components in
allowing the United States to calibrate
the war effort with the domestic economy
so that UN 1945 having won the war
without having to then you know we
revived your economic life and that's
what that's what a lot of the United
says be so powerful in 1945 because most
countries after fighting war like that
take years to rebuild internally well
you get back to this point you you were
talking about the creation of the
economy how these statistics or these
numbers allow the creation of the
economy and what you're also describing
here and you do very well in the book is
this fundamental shift to the government
had the ability much in a way mirrored
the Industrial Revolution to manage the
economy right and you could actually
look at these numbers and you could say
okay now we're going to move this much
here in this much here and everything
will still be okay in the end and this
is a new concept yeah and the only thing
that the government had done before that
should try to figure out how much more
revenue can I create right that was the
that was the sole challenge they think
of dynasties and kingdoms
time immemorial sorry how do I talk to
you this much right but the idea that
you have this thing called economic
policy where you calibrate and you try
to end economic cycles right the ups and
downs are just part and parcel of
history for one reason or another that's
all part of this sort of the Scientific
Revolution and the emergence of
centralized government and it is in fact
one reason why even today there is and
I'm sure will continue to be a deep seed
of suspicion in every society that all
these numbers GDP inflation unemployment
aren't actual numbers that reflect
experience of people they are ways for
government to exert control I don't
really go into that a lot in the book
and I think that's a whole kind of
another question and subject but it is
definitely one that underlies all of
this discussion people kind of listen to
these numbers they go oh come on
I particularly in you know that
inflation isn't telling me how much it
costs for me to live it's just a way for
government to prevent my cost of living
allowances from going up or something
like that well you actually touch and I
do want to talk about the conspiracy
theories around these numbers because
it's a fascinating aspect of it but you
touch on something basically post-world
War two when you describe how we enter
into this or this explosion of sort of
fascination with these economic
indicators and you have the growth of
yet new ones and private players start
to get involved and they start making
their own we can talk about a few of
those but one of the innovations this is
like a whole new area of kind of an
economic indicator and you have this guy
named George Katonah who starts to
measure and this gets to your point
about the people there's a measured
consumer sentiment and uses that as an
economic yes sir so kind of 1947 veggies
you have this efflorescence of numbers
and you'd had some before like there had
been housing associations have been some
purchasing managers you know the people
companies who buy stuff trying to figure
out what was going on nationally and
then you get these associations that
start going well government's creating
statistics so we're gonna create
statistics and then you have academics
uh who think okay well what are we gonna
add to this and and there was this kind
of quirky guy named George Katonah who
another emigres like Simon Kuznets the
United States came in the 1930s trained
both as a economist and as a gestalt
psychologists so if anybody remembers
the 1970s gestalt psychology was like a
big deal you know it was the gestalt and
without going into the that you know
that warrant of discussion his belief
was that how people think and feel
individually shapes their behavior
economically and therefore if you can
get a gauge of how people feel you're
going to get a gauge of how they're
about to act now initially that was
interesting actually for the government
during World War two because there's
always been an aspect of inflation in
prices that is based only on what people
perceive you know if you think things
are going to get cheaper you hoard you
won't spend if you think there's going
to be inflation you'll spend a lot now I
mean there's behavior that goes with
that expectation so they wanted to kind
of gauge and make sure that inflation
expectations were being kept tame and
they develop basic surveys five
questions you know do you feel good or
bad about the economy do you feel good
about your own personal finances do you
think it's going to be better in six
months or worse in six months and then
you took all those questions and all
those surveys and you added you created
numbers and then you created an index
and you created a number called consumer
sentiment which we now live with every
month from multiple sources there are
like three organizations now that
disseminate consumer sentiment
University of Michigan The Conference
Board ABC News for a while at a consumer
survey and it all begins from this kind
of Gestalt psychologists economists the
one thing that has only been clear since
then even that's really interesting like
a what people feel is that it's
predictive powers absolutely zero right
except in very harsh and and legit Elise
and his pushback was you can't test
whether or not this works by asking a
family six months later whether or not
they did what they said six months
before so it's not like about individual
behavior being predicted and that was
the whole Gestalt think it's about
patterns of if enough people say they're
not feeling good that might be a leading
indicator of evidence on any real
evidence of that either right but this
nonetheless remains in a second
important as we want not we've come to
be in a culture where we like numbers to
sort of describe reality but this this
is the point of this chapter is you talk
about in the 40s of 50s on the 60s to
you be you don't just have this this
huge spiraling of numbers but you have
the media really focusing on these
and business community's really focusing
on these and they become to be inter
woven in America's ideas of how we are
how we performing visa vie everybody
else uh correct yes and part of this is
you know there's a Henry Luce Time
magazine fortune Businessweek phenomenon
of you suddenly have this this these
outlets that talk about economic life
anymore the point you to think about the
nature of the Cold War and the degree to
which the Cold War because it was a cold
war when we were not fighting the Soviet
Union and it was perceived legitimately
as a contest of economic system
ideological ones but economic ones at
heart modes of production and so a lot
of the Cold War unfolds with whose
economic system is doing better and
who's making more stuff whose stuff is
better whose output is greater for big
on these and they have their own you
know grow Soviet product we heard we had
our gross national product and there's a
really famous debate between Nixon and
Khrushchev when Nixon was vice president
1958 we called the kitchen debate I
think was 58 where they're kind of
arguing about appliances and and part of
it is literally whose stuff is better
who's making more of its you have the
the nuclear weapons on the one hand and
then you had industrial output at the
other and then you'd all these nations
in the world kind of decolonizing
becoming new countries that had been
ruled by France or by Britain or by
Portugal and and one of the things that
you have to do when you join the UN is
you have to start measuring this thing
called your economy because if you're a
new nation you want economic aid from
the World Bank or from the International
Monetary Fund the criteria is you've got
to be able to show that that money had a
good effect so just like the the GMP was
created for the New Deal for Roosevelt
to show that the spending was working
the 1950s and 1960s if you're a new
African country or a new Asian country
and you want economic aid you have to be
able to show that it's improved your
economic life so you have to start
measuring GNP and GDP and you do so
according to mandates established by the
UN which are exactly the framework set
by the United States so suddenly by like
the late 1960s you go from a world where
no one talked about any of this no one
measured prices no one measured output
no a measured employment to a world
where every country in the world is
doing it and they're doing it exact
order to exact ly the same blueprint
and let's talk about that for a minute
because the UN part here is very
important UN the World Bank and IMF and
as you said there is this requirement
suddenly that you do this but what's
fascinating is why in that you describe
how you know you're coming out of World
War two and there's this fundamental
belief that one of the reasons things
went so wrong as you get a country
Germany that was having a great deal of
economic distress and this was part of
the motivating thing that pushed it into
war we don't want a situation like that
again we want to know where do economy
stand in the world because this is
somehow also going to allow us to manage
peace and stability right I think people
do and have in fact as you really well
point out forget the degree which even
the UN is formed half of it about
economic rights half of it's about
Economic Security there's actually an
Economic Security Council in the UN that
I think most of us unless you really
look at it are ignorant of we all know
about the Security Council right because
it was front and center in the Cold War
about States and problems but half of
the work of the UN was our more of it
was always about economic development
exactly in the belief that when there's
economic insecurity when you have things
like the Great Depression then that will
then lead to things like World War two
now that may be a completely wrong
thesis we you know we don't get to
replay the tape but it was clearly the
animating thesis and it led to this you
know just like there's a full if raishin
of nuclear weapons in the Cold War
there's a proliferation of economic
numbers whereby the entire world becomes
kind of indicated you know we we all now
measure our lives with this dashboard of
numbers in a way that before the 1950s
absolutely no one did one last thing
that you talked about in terms of what
inspired this huge growth as well too is
there's money in producing these things
too but a lot of these are produced by
private organizations you mentioned
George Katonah in his work he was at the
University of Michigan which I believe
has made a fair amount of dollars off of
producing some of these in there and
then businesses start paying for and
then Wall Street starts paying for and
that's a big factor here is and that's
really again a later one you have to get
into the 1970s and 1980s where people
start wanting a trading edge they start
trading on the numbers in the belief
that the numbers will then represent
something fundamental in economic
activity which I guess would have info
our corporate earnings right so the
numbers business becomes a huge one the
National Association of Homebuilders
starts putting out its set of numbers
the this Institute of Supply Management
starts putting out its numbers about
manufacturing activity and then the
Federal Reserve starts getting into the
act and starts doing regional
manufacturing surveys and again you have
this proliferation in a way that just
was sort of inconceivable and I think
one thing to that I bet that I try to be
really clear about in the book is that
just like we all individually have a
point of origin were born in a certain
time were shaped by that culture that we
grew up in all these numbers are born
within a few decades of each other
fundamentally and they are a product of
that time they are product of the 1930s
or 1940s and 1950s mostly and in that
respect they were designed at that
origin moment to measure that world and
they do a pretty good job measuring that
world they do pretty good job measuring
a world of industrial nation states that
make stuff but we don't live in that
world anymore and I mean I know that
we're now segwaying of it but it's it's
the reason to look at that history is to
try to understand who invented these
numbers to answer what questions at what
moment in time and is the world we are
now living in the same as that world
well actually the Segway is great
because let's talk a little bit about
all the problems with the fact that we
now have arrived in this period of time
in the world where we so do define
ourselves based on this indicator so one
of the things which you just mentioned
and you make a very strong fit case for
in the book is that these numbers are by
and large wholly inadequate for the
purposes for which they're used and one
of the descriptions I just loved is talk
about the iPhone and the way we measure
for instance the trade deficit and how
that might have worked at one point and
how it doesn't work in any way now to
adequately tell us what our trade
deficit is so to be very clear I do
think a lot of these are inadequate I do
think though I kind of honored the
degree to which they were not just
adequate but they were really important
when they were invented they're
inadequate the way a 1950's car which
was great you know and your parents and
your grandparents still remember the you
know the 1950 Chevy or whatever the car
they had as being this wondrous car and
it was but if I gave it to
today and said this is your car you know
no air conditioning no anti-lock brakes
really bad fuel mileage terrible pickup
on the roads you'd probably go you know
not such a great thing so trade numbers
which we talked about is being very old
in the sense of nations tended to get
revenue either from farming or from
tariffs on on trade trade numbers act as
if everything that we buy and purchase
is made in one place in one country and
I think in the 1950s when a lot of the
initial rules were codified even in the
1980s
the idea that an iPhone that a phone
that a washing machine is made in a
factory in one country and then as
either sold and bought in that country
or it's sent abroad to another place as
an export made some sense you know there
might have been parts that were
different but they were usually parts
that were sourced locally think of
Detroit yes a lot of those parts came
from Toledo and the steel came from
Pennsylvania but was still an American
car made of American parts so today an
iPhone which you know in many ways is
the quintessential American product
invented by this quirky genius and
Silicon Valley headquartered in
Cupertino California on and off the
largest company in the world every time
an iPhone gets sold in the United States
it registers as an import from China
why billions the trade deficit fillion 7
billion it's hard to know exactly but if
you had the iPad we're probably about 10
million dollars a year in those devices
alone Apple devices add to the trade
deficit with China because they are made
in factories many of which are in
Shenzhen which is in southern China so
they get made in that factoring they
could put on a container ship and they
show up at the Port of Long Beach and
they get assigned their wholesale price
which is a declared price that Apple
puts on it $200 $220 customs department
writes that down and it's a $200 import
or $250 import from China but is it
really right is anything that we now use
really made in any one country whether
it's a t-shirt where cotton comes from
one country and the pattern comes from
another and the swatches come and then
they're assembled it is clear that the
iPhone is assembled in a factory in
Shenzhen it is not clear that that $220
or 250 dollars goes from the United
States to China every time one is bought
because if you
break down that iPhone which a bunch of
economists have done in which the Asian
Development Bank has done in which the
Organisation for Economic Cooperation
and Development have done you find that
there are parts from Germany and parts
from Korea and parts from Taiwan and
plastic from somewhere else and parts
from America and above all intellectual
property right from the US but in a
world of trade numbers that assume that
a object has a final substantive
transformation in one country we've no
way of breaking any of that down well
also the fact to that it doesn't even
sell here in this country for what it is
marked down in the trade deficit in it I
mean I think the retail value when they
first came out was 499 dollars nobody
ever paid that much more because of
agreements with cellphone you know
prices and carriers right but I think if
you do this right you can do this for
every manufactured and many other goods
that aren't manufactured as heavily
furniture clothing and you would find
that the way in which value is dispersed
in global supply chains we just don't
know how to capture with a set of
numbers that assume that a thing is made
in one place whereas today most things
are made everywhere that the Boeing 787
Dreamliner
was possible because of information
technologies that allowed you to design
this plan on an AutoCAD computer system
and then source parts from dozens of
countries around the world
now every time it gets sold you know
when Boeing sells one from its factory
outside of Seattle to Japan Airlines it
shows up as a US export but it's not in
the way that we assume value-add flows
and we are doing I think just a really
bad job capturing it you know the even
worse news is I don't know how we change
that you know where no one's going to
spend billions of dollars to break down
tens of or hundreds of thousands of
goods into their various components and
so right now we're kind of we're stuck
with the figures we have but it's
creating an optic I think of what's
going on globally that's that's
profoundly wrong well in addition to the
complexity and living in a global world
of actually using these numbers and
Counting things the right way
you know you have the fact too that
these indicators many of them have been
and continued to be mired in controversy
in terms of you know you talked a bit
about the complexity that went into the
decisions about what you count and what
you're not going to
but he looks like you know think about
it well the one that we didn't talk
about but which you devote a chapter of
your book to on inflation you know there
is probably on a daily basis no more
controversial issue than the cost of
living right in this country because you
know people believe that the government
keeps it at a certain level so that they
can keep down Social Security benefits
that they have to pay out or so that
businesses don't have to pay their
employees as much on average and it's
just as this constant source of tension
which is all the more remarkable given
the kind of crazy decisions that go into
deciding how this is come up with and
whether or not it actually is a very
good indicator of anything yeah and part
of it is a misunderstanding what it's
what inflation as a government Consumer
Price Index is supposed to do it's
supposed to measure systemic price
stability it is not supposed to tell
Cameron Zachary whether or not our cost
of living is commensurate with our
income whether or not we're able to meet
our needs or our desires or both
relative to what we expect and so an
inflation becomes this real nub of
people's experience of their economic
lives versus our expectations versus
their ability to meet it and human
memory around prices and the movement of
prices is absolutely terrible I mean it
is clear at least from inflation numbers
as measured by the government's consumer
price index that the amount of money you
and I spend as a percentage of income on
food and fuel has gone down dramatically
since the 1950s but that's on our daily
experience of meeting our needs and to
be fair I actually think inflation
numbers that are kept by the government
are amongst the more reliable and and
some of the attempts to do different
methodologies you know Google Google
started creating its own inflation index
because it has all this information
flowing through its servers to MIT
economists created the billion prices
project which said hey instead of
sending out really expensive surveys you
cost hundreds of millions of dollars to
create these you just create a computer
program that takes online pricing in
real time what's interesting about those
alternatives is they don't diverge a
whole lot from our official inflation
numbers but the problem is what's the
question those indices answer versus
what are the expect expectations we
place on them publicly and again they're
not meant to tell us our cost of living
but
how we discuss them and and the other
problem with inflation is baskets of
goods change you know we're no longer
buying landlines and we have cell phones
the whole cellphone issue is a huge one
with these numbers and that so many of
our government statistics are dependent
on government statisticians calling you
on your phone at home so if you don't
have a phone at home if you have a cell
phone if you're 25 years old and you
don't have a landline the odds of you
being reached by these surveys is de
minimis because you know they want to
mess up the sample set you don't know
where someone is if they've got a cell
phone because you can take it with you
anywhere 25 year-olds don't tend to
answer survey questions nearly the same
rate so there's a whole other issue of
exactly where are we even getting our
information from well you have really
fun stories in the book about how I mean
this has been a problem since the start
about the quality of putting together
some of these samples and you know going
back you had the the first I think
unemployment calls that went out and you
were talking about a lot of these people
that were hired to do this were hired by
the Roosevelt government as part of the
government works program they weren't
statisticians they didn't necessarily
know what they were doing and apparently
the product from back then is one thing
they're all these surveyors who you know
it's a really boring job to knock on
doors and say are you employed what's
your profession so a bunch of guys got
really bored sat down in a corner just
started filling out the sheets
themselves and even today I mean they're
always lingering suspicions we had this
in the 2012 election about whether or
not you know these are numbers that are
cooked or somehow manipulated I think
that the likelihood of that is is really
low but you know there are such
complicated entities now with such vast
databases going into them that you do
have to ask what are we measuring versus
what do we think we're measuring well
that's what I wanted to ask you because
you do have a lawn there but the
controversies that have plagued this
ofyears and it goes way back you know
George Meany you ran the labor you know
Federation for a while you know was a
fierce critic of some of these numbers
he believed that they were being put out
as are typically to kind of ding the
unions and make it harder for working
people
good you go all the way up it to the
point you just made Jack Welch 2012
there was an argument about whether or
not the unemployment report had been
duped in some way but the question I
have for you is
isn't it maybe fair for people to wonder
that to some degree only because you
know your book in fact is all about the
kind of history behind some of this
there were people there were social
Crusaders who wanted to use these
numbers to some degree to create a new
social order injustice in the country
and that that was at least part of the
motivating idea behind these indicators
although I think today most the people
who are in charge of compiling them are
much more in that kind of like
technocratic bureaucratic statistician
you're just trying to answer the
question and if anything because of that
are not able to deal with these larger
questions of to what degree is even if
they're perfectly done
what are they measuring versus what is
the world we currently inhabit you know
I think the conspiracy question is
almost a secondary one relative to the
promise of these numbers versus what
they actually deliver is the real issue
is the real disjuncture and the hubris
of policymakers utilizing these numbers
and economists in particular as if there
are absolute patterns that emerge that
you can then know I mean one of the
things I'm most passionate about in this
is it so we'll talk about for a minute
you know when President Obama gets up in
2009 and makes his speech announcing the
stimulus bill and says with the 787
billion dollar bill we will create or
save 3.5 million jobs now I want to make
this really clear this is not a partisan
critique of the stimulus plan what
fascinated me is what allows the leader
of a country to get up and make with
such specificity a dollar amount of
spending with a job creation number
that's specific right that would have
been in consuming Roosevelt Lincoln
nobody got up and made that you you
would have said we're going to spend a
lot of money because there's a problem
and it's going to do good that's that's
in one kind of statement but to make a
formulaic number we're going to spend X
amount and create Y amount of jobs and
that comes out of a belief that we have
enough information enough data and
enough of these numbers that we know
that when government spends a certain
amount this amount of jobs gets created
right but if these numbers were only
invented in the middle of the 20th
century we don't know a lot you know we
don't know nearly as much as we think we
know to make
those kinds of statements on a routine
basis and Democrats and Republicans do
this about all spending bills you know
we we project out what we what we think
the effects are gonna and the
Congressional Budget Office which I'm
highly critical of not because they're
doing a bad job the entire conceit
behind it of we can know with any degree
of certainty the outcomes of these
things well in all this is happening at
a time and you make this point as well
that when in fact the economy has become
more complex right more difficult
government so you have a government that
on one hand has become ever more
self-assured about its ability to manage
this thing called the economy even as
this thing called the economy has become
ever more unmanageable yeah and then not
only unmanageable but but global so the
economy assumes that the nation is the
same thing right so every economy is
national but we've been talking for
twenty years now that the degree to
which we live in a global economic
system and it is certainly true in
everything we buy back to the iPhone
back to the Boeing plane you know we
live in a global supply chain we live in
a world where money flows globally and
so the idea that a set of 1950s national
numbers can adequately serve as our map
in kind of a 21st century world of
global international interchange and
then add in the role technology right
like how do you measure Google and GDP
right there was no information
technologies of the kind we have now
most of which we use for free so they
don't have a market price I mean the
only way some economists now are trying
to figure out what's the economic output
of free applications is to think of well
we all value our time if we're working
so if you're getting paid $30 an hour
$20 an hour and you take 15 minutes to
go into Google you're essentially
valuing your Google time at you know a
quarter of an hour of your work and then
multiply that by the amount of hours you
know people spend on Google now that's a
way to get at it right but is that
really the way to get we don't know how
to measure the output of these things
well in addition to the hubris which you
mentioned and the controversy that has
always played these and the kind of
inadequacy in a global world of how well
they can actually predict anything you
know you have this fun thing about the
difference between leading and lagging
indicator the idea of a lagging
indicator it's just weird to begin with
but there's also the fact that these
things have become and maybe maybe
actually you know it's justice the
politicians that helped inspire the
creation of these you know leading
indicators that they're very intervene
with politics right day and you had some
you know going all the way back you
talked about Hoover and the fact that
here he drove so hard to try to get some
measure of unemployment and it dinged
him in the end because people found out
unemployment was quite bad you know he I
mean my joking that is yet twice on his
own statistical but are like he creates
the number that then gets used against
them I mean I do I do think that as part
of it although and again every country
in the world now the Chinese government
right there they've made their entire
sense of legitimacy hinge on maintaining
a level of GDP growth and employment
creation that is statistically manifest
I mean these numbers have become our our
latter-day version of land and Empire
you know we measure our national
strength based on what these numbers
tell us and so we we we literally invest
them with this huge amount of weight and
it's impossible for them then not enter
kind of a political debate and political
dialogue even though again I feel like
we are capturing only one aspect of the
world we're living in because it's not
like there's this major global move or
anyone's gonna spend a lot of money to
reinvestigate our statistical framework
for the 21st century well I mean you
also mentioned not just China but
Argentina I mean it became a bit of a
global pariah because people felt it was
cooking its indicators I mean they they
really did try to cook their indicators
and in 2008 2009 the Kercher's fired the
the what would have been our Bureau of
Labor Statistics inflation Department
because they were routinely reporting
higher inflation then the curtains
wanted to be reported because it was
undermining their claim to economic
stewardship and then I mean it gets kind
of theater of the absurd here and I'm
sure there's an equivalent in Venezuela
and I'm sure you know North Korea
doesn't have a statistical agency
they've a and the set of numbers say
they write down the the group that got
fired tried to set up a non-profit group
to then be the real due diligence group
and then the Argentine government
stripped them
they're nonprofits that is to try to
prevent them from being the watchdog so
we at least don't have those issues in
most of them at least I mean that's
that's one saving grace well let me ask
you this and then I want to talk a
little bit about what we do about all of
this but before I do are we if you went
back and you looked at the world prior
to some of these leading indicators we
are we've even better off now you know I
think we were better off more problems
than we fix I think that I think the
problem of economic policymaking today
is it does hinge on a belief and this is
true no matter where you are in the
political spectrum that you can capture
what's going on statistically and then
manipulated effectively and the
realities business cycles have become
less intense you know the worst of our
up and downs today even with 2008-2009
are probably not nearly as severe as
they were throughout the 19th century or
before that you know we've we've removed
food famine on the one hand for most of
the world and you know even where it's a
problem with usually a political problem
not a food problem and we've removed the
worst of economic cycles in the sense of
you know you don't get 30 percent of the
work force out of work and you don't get
people literally on the streets by the
millions you think this is in part
because I think it's important as we
learn something about economic systems
but that's very different than how do
you deal with changed realities right I
think we're really good again at
managing the economic systems of the
past my real concern is we're kind of
again flying blind with the economic
systems of the present but we're using
the only map we've got you know so you
talk some in the book about movements by
some to create different indicators as
it were and you have this fabulous story
but the King of Bhutan I mean Todd and
this seems to go back you you actually
open the beginning of the book with this
speech this is a long-running theme that
the Robert Kennedy gave but all the way
back in the 60s saying railing against
GDP and saying you know we ought to be
measuring our confidence and the way we
educate our children and all these other
things that make up the great good
America and you still see that
dissatisfaction with and attempts by
others to come up with something better
yes I mean there was a big GDP backlash
in the 70s partly because GDP was seen
as encapsulating the materialism and
material
the size versus the softer values that
are important any society happiness
happiness and that's where this this
small Kingdom landlocked Buddhist
kingdom of Bhutan so look we should we
ought to be measuring aggregate
happiness it's not individual happiness
and all the all the Westerners who have
since kind of gone oh this would be
great if we would measure happiness and
forget that their happiness was pretty
collective you know and and we a lot of
us bet it would be rather unhappy with
their happiness again that the issue
there is not okay is that a better way
to measure something that GDP fails to
measure it's the idea that you could
come up with one number that adequately
tells you anything meaningful about the
world you're living in whether its
economic or otherwise you know one
number for 320 million Americans one
number for a million New Yorkers or a
million people in Bhutan what good does
one number tell you what number is
always a synthetic average of something
and maybe you can tell you something
about the system then the system now in
a kind of aggregate sense but GDP too
you know it tells you really very little
about most questions we have as
Americans about quality of life about
the sustainability of economic growth
about whether or not economic activity
today and the present is likely to be
sustained and augmented in the future
right because all output is neutral in
GDP if there's two hurricanes tomorrow
though that's really good for GDP
because you spend a lot of money
cleaning up after a hurricane but it's
not like you would say to fix America's
economic woes we should just have five
hurricanes
right but GDP would say that's a
perfectly fine way of doing it so the
question is what are there questions I
mean I tell us I'm trying to help people
I'm trying to help myself say we should
start with the questions and then find
numbers and find statistics that help us
answer them because all those numbers
were created initially to answer a
question a really important question
it's when they get detached from the
question they were meant to answer and
they get kind of enshrined as this is an
important number that you have real
problems and the people who created
these numbers understood that that's
what human beings do with statistics I
kind of enshrine them as absolute
without wit and forget what they were
meant to answer in the first place well
so this is this is your idea for the
solution rather than coming up with just
an alternate different indicate
right but rather as you said the spoke
indicator so it turned this entire
paradigm on its head and say what is the
question that we are trying to answer
and then look at the vast range of data
out there and get that yeah and I mean I
like the bespoke idea because it means
made-to-measure if you're gonna talk
about measuring things what are you
trying to measure and why so GDP has
become a you're supposed to GDP supposed
to grow because it's supposed to grow
because when it grows people's income
goes up and people's quality of life
goes up what we're seeing today in a lot
of parts of the world is in fact GDP can
grow quite a bit without income going up
you know if a robot and a factory is
going to produce what five hundred
people to factory used to produce that
factories output can go up without
creating any jobs so the the question
that GDP is supposed to answer is our
collective affluence going up if GDP
goes up may actually not be true
what then there's the question the
question is how do we have affluence go
what where is it doing well where is it
doing badly and we have more information
than ever before about all these things
and counties and ER demography yeah
where you live and and the one real
defense of these numbers today being
collected is that underneath every
number is vast amounts of information
every GDP report comes with hundreds of
tables every unemployment report dozens
and dozens every inflation report comes
with you know eight different
alternative inflation gauges by by
geography by consumption that
information is very useful we don't
really use that information usefully and
when you get down to the business and
individual level then you have to start
going these numbers do what right what
what is if I told you GDP is going up
two percent or down two percent and the
National Association of mortgage said
that there was X number mortgages and
house rates were why would you decide to
then buy a house or not buy a house on
the basis of them I mean I would hope
not and I get out fear that many people
are would I mean wouldn't some of this
just involve two going back to even the
most basic things that we have out there
I mean if you're in business and you
want to get a good sense of where things
are headed in your particular industry
why would you just look at prices
exactly and the price is in just that
area that actually pertained to your
industry
the one thing that's interesting is
think of the home example if you wanted
to buy a home today the thing you need
to know is the home prices in a ten-mile
radius the employment patterns you know
what's the local economic system that's
going to support the price of that home
including your own unemployment your
unemployment reality and is the bank
going to give you a loan you can do that
now by going onto Zillow or eight
different apps that give you all the
poems that were bought in the past 30
days if you wanted to do that 10 years
ago I'm not so sure how you get that
information you could have gone to the
city hall but with it might have been a
60-day lag so it was actually hard to
get that information it's actually
really easy now so the information that
we have that we need is really easy to
obtain and the information that we think
is really easy to obtain ie these
national numbers are completely
irrelevant the questions that you have
have you advocate we get rid of them I
don't ever get we get rhythm one because
they are the justification for a lot of
interesting information - I think if
policymakers use them more wisely and
look this is a great thing I get to
write a book and make that statement
with the full awareness that the
likelihood of that is minimal so but if
you know if we all woke up tomorrow and
and wisdom and maturity would there was
an outbreak of wisdom and maturity on
Capitol Hill like a like a really good
disease um you could use things like the
employment numbers to really get at
where are their employment issues in the
United States and why are they happening
which is very different than a national
rate that acts like it's the same and
Bethesda that it is in Detroit that it
is in Las Vegas comparative value here
by the right session say they say look
have a data set over time where you can
compare how things are now versus how
they are then I'm more skeptical that
because the the methodology is always
changing now half the time we're going
back and changing the data with the
methodology but I think that that that
these sets are not as useful as we think
they're I don't I don't think you can
easily go back to 1970 and go oh well
you know we built a factory and it
generated 300 jobs because we're
misunderstanding the nature of a factory
today in the nature of employment today
I think I mean one of the other things
that you mentioned too is it may be what
we need is a spectrum right I've kind of
possibilities and probabilities rather
than one definitive number you know and
we were talking earlier one thing that I
have noticed I mean the press itself
seems to have begun slowly slowly to
cotton on to the fact that some of these
leading indicators really don't tell us
as much as they should so I've noticed
that five years ago prior to the crash
they would report the monthly
unemployment number now when you turn on
the TV they often report the monthly
unemployment number and then they also
talk about the number of people have
dropped out of the workforce and all
these other kind of mitigate or other
questions involved so we do seem to be
moving to some realization that these
indicators don't want agree that I think
there's definitely some motion there and
some movement and and some evolution
that is inevitable and important as are
really thinking what's a better way of
capturing what we're living in
rather than the recourse to this pretty
limited framework even then though so we
talk about the unemployment rate and
whether you have a job and we act like
every job that gets created is a good
job it really is it I mean if you're
working 37 hours a week at $12 an hour
we should be talking about the quality
of the jobs and whether or not it's
allowing people to meet their means and
I'm just saying that neutrally meaning a
job is not necessarily a plus in the
absence of what is not necessary - if
you're 27 years old and you're
unimpressed
that's probably a good thing none of
that we we would use we would be able to
discuss constructively within our
current framework so you know do you get
rid of these numbers they offer a
pattern as to what's going on in the
world but a much looser one and a much
less useful one but we have massive
information in a big data world at our
fingertips that we can use really really
constructively if we allow ourselves
numbers numbers numbers don't want it to
be the bottom line thank you so much for
doing this today preciate it thanks